start a sit form if I were talking to
myself I would say calm down because at
the start of sick form I I was I was
very nervous paramarines just constantly
constantly thinking about what what am I
going to do I haven't heard about
interviews I maybe I didn't get it just
to chill out you know work hard but
mainly enjoying the subjects who are
doing advice well I think I'll probably
give the advice which I was given a year
before I applied and that is don't be
intimidated because like I said a year
before I actually applied we had one
student from our school and we came down
to visit him and he said don't feel as
though you're not good enough to come
here because it's it's not I mean that's
probably one of the another one of the
options stereotypes don't feel
intimidated if you feel like you might
like it go for it work consistently
don't leave also last minute because
people who work consistence consistently
don't have to do as much original yet
you still need to work hard at the end
but it won't be as much of a panic and
even if you feel you've forgotten things
they will be there whereas if you're
trying other things for the first time
in these holidays it doesn't work why
did you bury one of us show some
enthusiasm and the way you can show
enthusiasm is by reading around the
subject particularly for applying to PPE
you know I was never a big newspaper
reader when I was 17 18 that I could
probably say I read the newspaper maybe
once or twice a year things have changed
now everything's online so it's easier
but yeah I mean you know reads the news
if for example when I was applying to
some pizzas the second time I got really
interested in Zimbabwean and Congolese
politics and I was because I was
interested in African music it was like
a completely random tangential interest
and I just read around that lots and
lots and and I ended up talking about it
in one of my politics interviews for
almost half an hour and and it was a it
was a really great conversation and I
I enjoyed that I'd give the advice of
somebody to where you try hard to be
independent I know a lot of the time in
schools it can be quite difficult to be
independent in your work but if for
instance you haven't picked up a single
book before coming to Oxford a few off
your own back for your studies I think
you really need to start doing that with
his if although it's really nice to go
through your a-levels just getting what
the teachers give you and it can be very
easy to do that I think you'll really
struggle exert if you have a picture of
your books I wish I'd picked up more I
did start a six when we've my son given
myself is whatever you want to do if you
want to do law medicine journalism don't
think you have to apply for a career
obvious degree course in law medicine
journalism you can go straight directly
into these paths for this possible
conversion courses gradual entry
medicine jerk like broadcast journalist
and hem a course and there's something
doing one of those studies something G
find is really interesting and don't be
afraid to off the beaten path certain
subjects now might not see myself as
appealing when things are going through
the roof and when you know the economy's
will answer than ever but at the grief
lots of the grief locks that it's a
starting point you know spring balls the
rest of your life as the states that
you're passionate about you will enjoy
it more will find it a lot easier and it
really will open like so many gateways
to you I think if I was to go back and
start again I would say look at putting
design up uni applications for really
last minute
I applied books but I've read my new
passport like two days for actually have
to do I know I'm read it through or
anything I was really happy thing that
it was just awful but if you give
yourself time to think about and think
about what you're putting into a person
say for the things like so good things
definitely won heads up because I've got
panicking and bringing six books talks
with my auntie that
she might not sure they don't say yeah
just don't don't kind of with the person
I'm staying with don't be afraid to brag
because it's the hardest thing because
it's the most erotic how amazing you are
how watching the other place that you
have to do ya advice just just go
throwing you nothing to lose if you're
applying and if you get rejected to the
other nurse or else and you know
everything that you're going to be happy
but don't worry really to you know if
you request then those chances are you
doing it right and enjoy it you know if
you'll get in it so that opportunity to
have stuff for you Minister stimulating
debate with some of the similar Suites
on lines on the subject that you're
interested